Salut ! Tous les lundis sur ma chaîne YouTube,
c'est le jour du Vlog.
A chaque fois, je vous emmène dans l'un
des endroits où je suis allé dans la semaine,
un endroit que je trouve particulièrement intéressant.
Mais dans les commentaires, vous m'avez fait remarquer
que je vous ai jamais fait voir où est-ce que j'habitais,
donc je vais vous faire voir aujourd'hui !
Dans les commentaires de ce week-end,
vous êtes nombreux à penser que j'habite à La Rochelle.
Alors non, j'habite pas à La Rochelle.
Je suis né à La Rochelle, j'y ai vécu la majeure partie de ma vie...
Toute ma famille est encore là-bas,
certains de mes amis sont encore là-bas,
mais maintenant j'habite à Paris.
Et plus précisément, j'habite ici.
C'est ici, dans cette cour, que les gens regardent
le mec qui se filme par la fenêtre, et qui comprennent pas
ce que je fait en fait.
Alors ça, évidemment, c'est mon immense terrasse
pour manger l'été...
Vous vous souvenez de l'été ?
C'est un concept dont vous vous souvenez encore ou pas ?
C'est...c'est quand à partir du mois de juin il fait beau.
Pas quand il fait ce temps-là dégueulasse.
On arrive dans la pièce principale.
Oui, j'habite au rez-de-chaussée,
j'habite au rez-de-chaussée mais c'est pas très gênant,
puisque comme les premiers bâtiments sont très éloignés,
j'ai quand même pas mal de luminosité !
Et en plus je peux observer les voisins...
Ha ha ha, le psychopathe !
Ici, vous avez l'espace repas comme qui dirait,
où nous pouvons manger.
Un autre espace repas, plutôt dédié à Vanille...
Et quand elle a bien mangé,
elle prend les partitions, et joue un petit peu de guitare...
Ça c'est des graines de menhir que j'ai ramené de Carnac. Je vous recommande.
Ça fait pousser des menhirs, et comme on peut le lire :
"Il faut les planter dans un sol celte et humide"
"La croissance par contre est très lente les premiers siècles"
Je pense pas que ce soit une arnaque.
Je pense que c'était vraiment une bonne affaire.
Les lumières. Avec lesquelles vous pouvez me voir en temps normal.
Et alors à côté de la lumière, il y a tout ce que j'appelle le "home-staging".
hein ! C'est-à-dire ...
de jolis objets faits maison.
Heu...on appelle ça du tout-ikéa !
...quasiment.
L'espace salon bien sûr. Voilà où je peux m'asseoir pour regarder la télévision.
Cette vidéo est d'une importance capitale quand même j'ai l'impression, hein ?
Bon en même temps c'est vous qui avez demandé...
Le lit de Vanille, si souvent squatté par Tamalo !
Et ça c'est le spot de Tamalo...à la base.
Et ça c'est le grattoir de Tamalo, grattoir qu'il utilise très peu
puisqu'il est beaucoup plus intéressant d'utiliser
ce fauteuil !
Hein ? N'est-ce pas ?
Ou alors, ce canapé.
Voilà, merci beaucoup Tamalo, d'avoir un petit peu personnalisé toutes les affaires de cette maison !
Mais bon vous allez me dire : "c'est qu'un siège et qu'un canapé !"
Oui oui, c'est qu'un siège et qu'un canapé, ou même tous les autres sièges de cette maison.
Et je pense qu'un jour je vais brûler ce chat.
Dommage qu'il n'y ai pas une vidéo 666, sinon on l'aurait fait là !
Et sa nourriture !
Pourquoi la nourriture de Tamalo est en haut ? Parce que sinon
Vanille mangerai la nourriture de Tamalo.
Mais
Tamalo a pris beaucoup de poids, c'est-à-dire qu'il est en régime en ce moment.
Mais le régime ne fonctionne pas très bien, car en le mettant au régime je me suis rendu compte
qu'il grossissait puisqu'il allait taper dans les croquettes de Vanille !
Que je peux pas mettre en hauteur, elle...
Déjà parce que Tamalo pourrait y aller,
et parce que Vanille n'a pas la condition physique pour aller au dessus d'une marche.
Voilà la cuisine !
Si on allait plus loin, on verrait donc la chambre qui est derrière cette vitre.
Là il y a le couloir, où au fond il y a la buanderie, les toilettes, ect..
La salle de bain.
Je vous fais quand même voir la salle de bain parce qu'elle a un petit truc sympa !
C'est-à-dire que la vous voyez l'évier et puis la douche, évidemment...
mais surtout... cette petite baignoire !
Et ça à Paris : douche et baignoire, c'est tellement rare,
que je me la raconte dans la vidéo !
Mais j'ai bien conscience que si vous voyez cette vidéo de Province,
ça vous paraît tout à fait normal, comme type d'appartement.
J'en ai bien conscience.
Mais nous à Paris, dès qu'on a plus de 8 m², on se sent un petit peu
les rois de Wall Street.
Et nous allons terminer par l'endroit que vous connaissez un petit peu, qui est le bureau.
Je vais vous le faire voir d'un petit peu plus près.
La cour où on était tout à l'heure, avec l'espèce de jungle devant, d'ailleurs.
Et à chaque fois qu'il y a des gens qui passent
ils me regardent parce qu'ils voient toutes les lumières,
ils voient un mec parler devant la caméra.
Je pense qu'ils se demandent vraiment ce que je fais dans la vie ici.
Ça c'est un flightcase que je me suis fait faire sur mesure il y a des années.
Des sets de valises de #ViensTeFaireMentaliser.
Ça c'est une partie de tous mes livres.
Dont certains dont je vous parle de temps en temps
Ah, il faudrait que je vous fasse une vidéo sur la lecture rapide un de ces quatre,
Dites-moi dans les commentaires si la lecture rapide ça vous intéresse ! (vidéo 177)
C'est fait pour lire plus vite, comme son nom l'indique.
Et enfin mon spot de travail, là où je passe ma vie, en fait
sur ce bureau !
Je vais vous faire grâce des toilettes qui n'ont pas grand chose d'intéressant,
la buanderie c'est pareil. La chambre, bon bah ma foi y a un lit...
Et le couloir, et alors, est d'une originalité extrême !
Je préfère vous faire voir les quelques pièces dans lesquelles je vis, quand même.
Et dans lesquelles Tamalo dort en permanence, je viens de le voir juste là.
Dis bonjour au MentalVlog Tamalo, voilà !
Là tu sais ce qu'ils font les gens ils cliquent sur J'aime parce qu'ils voient ton petit ventre.
[ronronnements]
Evidemment si vous voulez pas faire de peine à Tamalo,
je vous recommande de laisser un petit
pouce en l'air !
Vous pouvez également commenter cette vidéo
c'est vous qui l'avez demandé donc vous l'avez demandé, vous l'avez eu.
Pensez également à vous abonner avant de quitter la vidéo
parce que le MentalVlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an.
CIAO !